voilà
non
vois ça peut-être
la plus énergique
on va faire un bond à moins que
oui
si bien qu est ce que tu fais tu répètes
à nouveau pas de danse crois qu'à
quelques est-ce que ça qu'est ce que ça
vient le julie te demande ce que tu es
en train de de nominer ou nous danser ni
l'un ni l'autre à je cherche une pause à
eau on va te prendre en photo qui misera
sans doute pour la gazette de l'île aux
enfants non vous n'y êtes pas du tout
monsieur du snav va faire marche statut
haut ainsi j'ai d'ailleurs ma statue
sera ici au milieu du jardin et ainsi je
serai toujours parmi vous les enfants
pourront faire des rondes autour de ma
statue ou jouer à cache cache derrière
mon dos c'est une très très bonne idée
mais casimir tu sais ça a demandé
beaucoup de travail il est alors que du
pause immobile sans bouger pendant de
très longues
non non tu n'as rien compris françois ce
n'est pas moi qui vais rester au milieu
du jardin c'est ma stature mais où et
casimir me françois a raison quand
monsieur du snd travaillera et qu'il te
prendra pour modèle tu seras obligé de
rester de longues heures immobile ah bon
mais c'est affreux au noir attendent ici
non non ça ne va pas mais où vas tu es
bien j'ai réfléchi je crois que mme
achta tout sera beaucoup plus belle
allonge et alors je vais chercher des
coussins
je pense que casimir vous a dit que
j'allais faire sa statue
évidemment le modèle est ce qu'il est
mais avec mon talent tu les enfants
pourra bientôt s'enorgueillir d'avoir
une vraie pièce de musée
vous croyez que ce sera aussi beau que
ça monsieur villeneuve nous voyons ma
chère amie tout ce que je fais très très
beau d'ailleurs si j'veux qu'on descend
à immortaliser dans la pierre ce gros
balourd c'est par pure amitié pour vous
deux oui d'habitude je ne fais que le
plan serait de très grande qualité au ce
que vous pouvez être snob monsieur du
snob mois ci nomme eh bien oui et j'en
suis fier
écoutez que je suis
[Musique]
j'ai chassé le lézard vert pendant trois
jours au congo j'ai jouer à saute d'un
point avec un chef eskimos
je suis triste chaque jour je colle un
gros oeuf d'autruche à mon petit
déjeuner j'ai chanté un opéra dans la
rue à tombouctou trouver les trésors
zaka dans un musée du pétrole
gens s'arrachent mais au togo
on m'a reconnu dans un heureux de mon
quartier je
suis un champion dé la sculpture
je
fait les chefs-d'oeuvre en peinture je
suis le plus fort plus beau le plus fort
je connais le fils du frère de la
belle-soeur de marquis c'est un homme de
qualité la preuve c'est qu'il me l'a dit
reims notre corps
nicole un gros oeuf d'autruche à son
petit déjeuner
il sépare les trusts off avec un accent
anglais
moi j -h beaucoup mieux avec la sam à
payer
j'ai lu talent c'était
de tout marche sous la célébrité jeu
[Musique]
suis un champion de la sculpture
heureux
je
les chefs-d'oeuvre de peinture je suis
le plus grand le plus beau le plus
il m'arrive quelquefois de faire rentrer
un peu fou je m'appelle monsieur durand
et j'ai les mêmes mots
jeanne supplice mort alors je colle
un petit oeuf de poule qui me rend tous
des primaires
matin quand je m'éveille j'oublie mon
rêve et c'est bien je vois ma calme en
chapeau et mon costume italien
je redeviens snow alors
un groupe d'autres chats mon petit
déjeuner
[Musique]
voilà monsieur du snav me voici
ramenés seulement pour un une minute
mais kazemi ou battus avec tous ses
cousins c'est pour prendre la poche je
serai très bien allongé sur tous ces
coussins tatata tu allongé jamais grâce
à moi la statuette dorée sera mieux du
jardin pierre martial orgueilleusement
j'aimerais surtout qu'elle soit sympa
soit mais debout bon ce sera quand même
pas trop longs et coûteux casimir si tu
veux être à jamais immortalisée par pull
bear en selle mots justes noces c'est à
dire moi il te faudra certainement un
peu de patience bombay le perdons pas de
temps que je dois faire quelques
esquisses avant de travailler la pierre
je cherche à l'imposer voilà qu'en
pensez vous chers amis
moi je trouve que ça ne représente pas
tout à fait le le casimir que nous
connaissons non moi je le ferai dans une
pose plus plus naturelle plus naturel
oui je ne vois vraiment pas casimir
debout ne bouge pas bon mais c'est
parfait comme ça car oui en effet comme
ça tu bouges et sympathique et le garde
aussi le côté bonhomme du personnage bon
on ne bouge plus casimir je fais deux
premières esquisses bon moi je vous
laisse travailler j'ai à faire bon
courage oui à bientôt pour chasser sur
burning plus bas
[Musique]
julie ne bouge plus m'enfin je n'en
bouge pas je parle j'ai quelque chose
d'urgent a demandé un joli bond mais
vas-y me dit
est ce que tu pourrais me préparer un
petit sandwich je commence à avoir faim
d'accord j'ai tout ce qu'il faut dans
vos murs parfaite du bouge sans arrêt je
peux pas te dire mon dessin reprend
[Musique]
qui tua des caprins mais oui bien sûr
avec de la crème et du chocolat
écoute casimir je ne peux pas saisir ton
att si tu t'arrêtes pas de bouger
de la confiture de groseilles avec le
jambon n'est ce pas oui mais qui signent
on ne pousse pas monsieur jean hommes de
ta fac pourtant comme vous comprenez les
difficultés des artistes moins chers
amis mais ce dessin est capital pour
commencer à attaquer la pierre car je
choisis une matière rare le marbre de
carrare la
moutarde bien bien mélanger avec le
chocolat c'est ce cas c'est bien je ne
peux pas me concentre été trop
indisciplinés
ne glisse pas le poivre surtout
[Musique]
formidable on y est magnifique
ça y est monsieur du snav je suis prêt
mais il enfin casino tu n'avais pas
entendu tout à l'heure il fallait
attendre la pause pour le manger bon
écoute maintenant tu n'as que sa faille
un bon allez faisons une pause ça tu
prends la balle et je vous remercie
monsieur disney voyez vous un ce que
j'aime moi dans la pause ce sont les les
petites pauses à
part à propos julie pourrais tu déjà me
préparer à un autre sandwich pour tout à
l'heure au cabinet